en réaction à l'attaque du 7 octobre les
tirs se sont multipliés à la frontière
entre Israël et le Liban ce qui fait
aujourd'hui craindre l'entrée en guerre
du Hezbollah pour soutenir son allié le
Hamas mais que valent réellement les
capacités militaires du hzbollah cette
organisation a-t-elle les moyens
d'entrer en guerre contre
Israël mouvement de résistance milice
État dans l'État les expressions
utilisées pour désigner le Hezbollah
sont nombreuses le Parti de Dieu c'est
une organisation politique sociale
religieuse et militaire aujourd'hui
considérée comme terroriste par l'Union
européenne les États-Unis mais aussi la
Ligue arabe elle née en 1982 pendant la
guerre civile libanaise officiellement
pour lutter contre l'occupation
israélienne la fin de la guerre civile
libanaise est bien marqué par les
accords de taf qui qui marque aussi le
désarmement de toutes les milices à
l'exception du Hezbollah qui maintient
son arsenal en dehors du contrôle de
l'État à travers l'argument aire de la
garantie de défendre la souveraineté
territoriale du Liban le hzbolla est
très largement financé et soutenu par
l'Iran c'est une organisation chite il
partage donc les mêmes intérêts face à
Israël le hzbola est soutenu par l'Iran
de plusieurs manières dans un premier
temps par la formation militaire un
certain nombre de cadres du hzbollah ont
été de CADES militaires ont été formés
entraînés par l'armée iranienne on sait
également que l'Iran a toujours soutenu
financièrement avec d' en montant qui
n'ont jamais été communiqués au public
le hzbolla à la fois sa montée en
puissance politique mais aussi sa montée
en puissance militaire ce soutien lui
permet à partir des années 1990 de
développer ses capacités militaires
jusqu'en 2006 qui marque un tournant
pour la branche armée du sbol 2006
marque bien la guerre des 33 jours qui
elle va en l'espace donc de d'un mois
parvenir à faire établir un nouvel
équilibre de la dissuasion de part et
d'autre de la ligne ligne bleu qui
sépare les territoires israéliens et
libanais puisque au lendemain de cette
guerre sal n'a en fait atteint aucun de
ces objectifs ouvertement formulés et ça
a eu des effets à long terme puisque de
2006 jusqu'à 2023 il n'y avait plus eu
de de de conflit de haute intensité sans
être aussi puissante que tsal qui
dispose d'une supériorité technologique
la branche armée du Hezbolah a su
montrer qu'elle pouvait représenter une
menace contre Israël pres-ce qu'on
ignore exactement queles sont ces
capacit
militair le chef Dubol est toujours
resté opaque sur les effectifs et
l'arsenal de son organisation la
dernière fois qu'il s'est exprimé à ce
sujet c'était en octobre
2021 Hassan nasrala le chef du hbolin
disait il y a 2 ans estimé sa force à
près de 100000 personnels mobilisables
100000 c'est peut-être un tout petit peu
exagéré néanmoins il est vrai que le
haszbollah dispose d'une d'une réserve
de miliciens extrêmement importante on
pourrait estimer certains chercheurs le
font en tout cas à 30000 miliciens
d'actif c'est-à-dire qui sont tout le
temps là et peut-être 50000 personnes
qui peuvent être appelé comme des
réservistes de manière un peu plus
générale dans un des filet récent on a
pu voir à la fois des armements
chenillés mais aussi des des des chars
ou des blindés on sait également qu'ils
ont des missiles sol sol sol air qui en
cas d'un engagement par exemple
israélien au sud du Liban pourrait
frapper très durement l'armée
israélienne avec un tel arsenal la
branche armée du hzbollah serait plus
puissante que les brigades elkassam du
Hamas l'organisation est souvent
considéré comme l'acteur non étatique le
plus puissant de la région le hezbola a
un avantage militaire c'est connaiss
ence du terrain et la préparation qu'il
a faite en amont depuis plusieurs années
il y a des endroits fortifiés il connaît
les endroits dans lesquels il pourrait
tendre des embuscades dans ce type de
conflit que l'on peut appeler de
d'asymétrique l'avantage est toujours
difficile à à conserver pour une armée
qui serait une armée d'occupation en
l'occurrence l'armée israélienne dans la
mesure où on a déjà fait ce dont il
était capable en 2006 tout laisse à
croire que le hzbolah a bien entendu les
moyens d' infliger euh de sérieux dégâts
à Israël en cas d'embrasement régional
pour l'instant alors tout le monde
touche du bois pour que ce ne change pas
le hzbollah reste à la fois très
anti-israélien et se montre aussi
déterminé que jamais dans son effort de
de de résistance jusqu'au bouhiste à
long terme face à face à l'État hébreux
mais en même temps a bien marqué une
certaine retenue tactique de depuis le 7
octobre cette retenue tactique elle
s'explique par la stratégie du hzbola
qui repose avant tout sur la dissuasion
mais elle s'explique aussi par la
situation interne du Liban le hzbollah
est le parti politique le plus puissant
du pays il utilise régulièrement son
veto pour bloquer les décisions qui ne
sont pas dans son intérêt sauf que la
crise économique sans précédent que
traverse le Liban depuis 2019 handicape
le hzbollah faut pas oublier non plus
que dans le contexte actuel le principal
gardefou qui explique aussi la frilosité
du Hezbollah à entrer dans un scénario
de guerre ouverte c'est justement la
pression en interne le Liban depuis 2019
est un état en faillite nasrala ne peut
pas sur un coup de tête traîner le pays
dans une guerre dont on connaît une des
conséquences c'est que l'aviation
israélienne raserait en gros toute
l'infrastructure routière de toutes les
circonscriptions du
[Musique]
pays